nous retrouvons aujourd'hui aux
dominicains de haute alsace qui est un
peu le centre de ce canton de guebwiller
aujourd'hui qui est le regroupement des
cantons de soultz guebwiller avant
l'année 2015
ce canton est donc se situe donc
globalement sur trois 3 vallées leva la
vallée du florival donc à billère et
lons à porte d'entrée mais aussi le
vignoble avec orschwihr bergholtz
bergholtz zell et puis le vallon
greenback sans oublier bien sûr la
plaine avec ses villages de merxheim
grain et raedersheim
nous sommes sereins cantons riches aussi
en patrimoine peu comme ici aux
dominicains de haute alsace mais aussi
avec tout l'art roman qui se trouvent
sur ce canton notamment avec l'abbaye de
murbach l'église saint léger dans le
haut de la ville de guebwiller et puis
l'église saint michel à lautenbach et
c'est aussi un canton de musée puisque
nous comptons pas moins de quatre musées
avec le musée théodore deck sur gaby
l'air le musée du but ce n'est que du
jouet à soultz et le musée du vigneron à
wuenheim ce canton a la particularité
d'être le regroupement des 18 communes
de la communauté de communes de la
région de guebwiller ce qui est aussi un
avantage surtout pour nous élus puisque
nous avons le même périmètre pour les le
canton et pour notre et pour la
communauté de communes nous nous
trouvons maintenant dans le coteau du
chum berg au milieu des vignes de
vignobles chaume berger de guebwiller
qui est le célèbre bien sûr pour ses
terrasses avec ses magnifiques murs en
pierres sèches et nous dominons la ville
de guebwiller où on peut voir en
arrière-plan
les friches industrielles et surtout
lusine nicolas chou berger qui est
historique dans dans les billère nous
travaillons donc beaucoup avec
l'entreprise selon mme berger
et nous avons un partenariat puisque
l'entreprise a souhaité se diversifier
et créer et fabriquer des vis
d'archimède pour la production
d'électricité
il ya une vie ce qui est installé sur la
loge qui est derrière nous et d'autres
vices sont encore sont installés ou en
cours d'installation sur le canal dans
la plaine du rhin donc économiquement
bien sûr nous nous retrouvons sur le
milieu de du canton avec bien sûr
différentes entreprises comme mayer sans
boeuf qui travaillent sur le textile
avec des produits tout à fait novateur
mais aussi une usine comme ce final qui
fabrique du lait de soja qui est à
issenheim et qui est en pleine leurs
exploitations et qui va doubler sa
production dans les années qui viennent
vous avez vu les dominicains de haute
alsace tout à l'heure vous voyez le
vignoble qui compte pas moins de cinq
grands crus sur ce que sur ce secteur
donc venez à guebwiller